[Music]
if not eternity news Oh some of the body
what's cooler than being cool ice-cold
from a charity is now shutting down
after reports surfaced of inappropriate
behavior at fundraising galas what's
inappropriate behavior getting bangs for
charity oh that sounds great
did you know that a Burning Man they
have a huge orgy tent and believe it see
that there that place is a dusty sex
fest yeah I mean it's cool i I support
it do your thing but I just wonder what
it smells like in there probably just
does everything Thank You Ana Burning
Man just looks like a bunch of stinky
white people to make it's like some
steampunk like road warrior [ __ ] I've
always wanted to go cuz that's a meet
you in like I was go-go dancing for like
raves surprise you know people aren't
like every year my friends like might my
white my white people friends my
spiritual if I can fire-eater fans
they're like yeah let's [ __ ] go I'm
like but you know during that time I'm
not [ __ ] broke twenty something years
old and it's [ __ ] expensive as [ __ ] I
would just have to be around a lot of
people that I want to [ __ ] up thanks
really much Glenn I heard that Burning
Man is actually way better than raves be
as of so much energy and effort from all
these artists some people prep like you
know the brewery which is an artist
colony yeah some of them they prep all
year long their crafts and like moving
things and whatever all year long just
for the Burning Man event yep so it's
like a huge art fest - they've been
telling me to go since I was like 19 but
it's such a huge commitment to go week
long it's the desert it's hot as [ __ ]
but I can run around naked that's fun
yeah so anyways there's this London
charity that's not dead yeah it's
clothing now after these two undercover
Financial Times reporters went into this
event because it's a all-male event the
only female there are the hostesses hot
stuff that's already there doing BUTT
STUFF
so there are about 130 hostesses that's
a lot in about 300 men oh so it said
okay it's called the president Club I
don't want to share yeah that's like two
guys to one girl mm-hmm yeah quick mess
yeah goodness yeah and it's about a
six-hour event it's tiring
well here's some still please tell me
they wear masks at least no this is like
an undercover or like from the
undercover video this is this screenshot
here and also this is a photo from now
they're all old and gross that door just
to hold I mean what is it is just a
secret sex club yeah what kind of
charity is so pretty much the whole
thing is that they're hiring these women
who don't really know what's happening
once they're there
oh that's [ __ ] up like all these
peplum is like oh you know some of the
guys will be annoying that's it but they
don't actually tell them like you are
gonna get groped like oh oh it's a grope
fest pretty much so what's the charity
form where they got donate the money for
like Children's Hospital or something Oh
squeeze a titty and give a donation
squee that did he say the baby yeah that
reminds me of when I was younger and
they were hiring models for like a poker
game and then it was one of those like
illegal poker games and like someone's
penthouses like high high stakes
whatever it was like yeah it's just a
poker game you show up and you're just
like dressed up super pretty you don't
have to be like exposed or anything and
you just serve them drinks and you get
tips I'm like all right cool that sounds
[ __ ] dope early 20s [ __ ] I need
money inna and then I go I'm like oh wow
this is really cool it's like a really
high-end like penthouse it's so nice and
there's girls there and then we're
waiting in the room and the head girl
comes in and she was like hey so this
guy wants you and then me you and you
two like grabbing some drinks and then
can you sh points at me she goes and can
you like give a massage give him a
massage during the time we squeeze his
shoulders and he's like shirtless I was
this area was hairy Arabic guy and I was
like wait what like I didn't see him
when I first came in you know they call
it hold on what she's like yeah he just
wants a massage don't worry they'll pay
you like five hundred for it I'm like
they do that a lot at the poker table
you get yeah but like if it's at a
casino like a big casino like what yeah
they usually have like massage therapist
like they're not even sexual they're
gonna do it they're [ __ ] going in
like these guys been sitting for 12
Danny pack with all their [ __ ] oils
exactly we're just going in and in the
guys line mmm i falled so like I look
out in like the poker room and there's
like these girls like ah yeah and that
and I'm like they're just like so it's
like a hostess club huh I would hate it
if I'm trying to get a massage it Lisa
Holly shut the [ __ ] up yeah massage me
[ __ ] what the hell I told her about my
[ __ ] day [ __ ] I don't see if I'm
playing poker
yeah don't distract me Tommy sorry I
told the head girl I'm like I don't
think this is for me she's like are you
sure you'd like to stick around but what
about the [ __ ] kids not a Children's
Hospital
what bankrupt if you want a massage dude
yeah so it's just like I'm not into this
funnily enough I ran into a girl who's a
sister of another girl whom I exploit
and cheat on me with and she was like
we're so we're cool right I'm like get
the [ __ ] out my face and I left you get
that five hundred bucks
good for you probably those girls make
like three or four K and night rose I
don't but their dignity is nowhere to be
yeah you have no standards I applaud you
I would have been one of those girls for
G's the night yeah that's why it may
look like a [ __ ] and I may look like a
bimbo gamer she's a big ass Tommy I am a
tomboy it's so bad show them you show
them your wardrobe right now this is the
perfect moment
and show the truth so I'm doing so um on
its its business on top its girl on top
its girl on top for like JK and then
barbell on the bottom does it get more
top than that so people don't understand
like so are you a tomboy or you girly
I'm like I'm both but I'm most of the
time I'm just a [ __ ] boy you don't
even have a purse you have looking a gun
holster Thank You Prince I'm a gun cool
sir but at the same time I like luxury
things I don't know man I'm stuck in
between being a ho and just being lazy I
don't know man I'm just Hosie I'm a lazy
ho ho's II see that's like when they
hire models we don't tell me that's
[ __ ] up what about the kids the
financial funding for this Children's
Hospital are they gonna do that money
you can't give them massages
I think they get in the Gotha gala right
yeah 300 men ready to pay for kids the
way Cal is usually work I don't know if
there's additional stuff is you buy a
ticket to be a part of it but it's
really a donation that you're doing but
to say thanks they host this event yeah
and you have dinner I also had auctions
for certain prizes so that's how they
were able to gain I get more money
nothing to do with the hot girls mmm
that's rude so what if this thing has
been giving hospitals millions of
dollars and now they just ruined that
and the hospitals don't get millions
that's exactly a null for little Timmy's
chemo you're a [ __ ] so what what
constitutes
Asgrow being in this case so I'm going
to show you guys a video of one of these
financial time reporters her talking
about her experience when she was there
this is one of the Undercovers but she
signed up as a hooker no hookers hostess
sorry I was great several times and I
know that there are numerous other
hostesses he said the same thing that
happened to them yes it's hands up
Scott's handsome that's good but also
hands on hips hands on stomachs on zero
waste unexpectedly I mean this isn't I
suppose high-level great thing but one
of the strangest things was you could be
talking to a man and it's only just
start holding your hand is the one who's
been running for 33 years from women
who've worked at it over the last decade
which is why we wanted to go in there
and see it for ourselves I have one
women tell me that she was shocked she
was asked if she was a prostitute on the
night so the worst I was told by one of
the hostesses was a man taking his penis
out in the during the course of the
dinner the other one was another man is
having a hostess - down her glass of
champagne rip off her knickers and
thoughts on the table if you want to run
an event where women are voluntarily
walking in there in the knowledge that
they will be groped yeah then fine make
that clear in the hiring process but
that wasn't made clear and there are
plenty of women in there who had
absolutely no idea what they were
letting themselves in for yeah I feel
like if it was fully consensual it can't
find a house you know 30 hookers I'm
pretty sure they can all right yeah I
can do it and they just got to change
their indeed post a little bit better
right just right you're gonna get growth
looking for people that love to get
growth it's funny because at that same
event they hand out these like flyers or
brochures or whatever like to see what
parchment apartments the paper you have
to talk like that in these papers they
have like what they're gonna be
auctioning off like dinners with
so-and-so or whatever and then also they
write like no groping is allowed like no
inappropriate touching oh that's for
legal reasons do the charity like washes
of hands from like just in case we'd
rolled I'm not to do it I can't control
them
this charity will no longer be going on
what you set up another charity with odd
or different I'm pretty sure they are
yeah and then also the hospital the
Children's Hospital that receive that
money has announced that they're gonna
be returning it why they don't care
about the kid I take it because if you
return they're gonna use that money for
something else
yes not you're falling for the kids the
kids aren't gonna be like ill that's
crapping money I don't want it like no
I'll make my shots mum we're not gonna
pay for the cancer treatments because
this is dirty money yeah I mean it
happened so take the money but only the
oddballs month is hooker dollars if they
were just upfront about it it wouldn't
even be a problem yeah I'm sure you can
find hella hoes that would love to do
this you know pleasure for the kids
mm-hmm some sweet for the key is that
auntie what some people that's the
president
of charitable trust and guys sign up
knowing that they're gonna get some
[ __ ] sure dude it's been for 33 years
I'm pretty takes place at a hotel oh my
god
so they could just go up to the room
what is the average price for a sexual
escort average I don't I my friend's
price is about 3 or 4 G's I don't think
that's an average does she what does she
do though everything I don't know what
she she does everything I know that she
does have sex if she needs to she wants
you but like she told me she say a lot
of times I guys just want to [ __ ]
chill and get high and watch Game of
Thrones
that's [ __ ] shitty I don't tell you
about the job she's not bullshitting
like that's it's the same girl I've been
talking about this [ __ ] is making like
well over six figures a year she's good
at what she does so I mean high high-end
escorts because she does she does that
girlfriend experience thing where people
were buying for her time and for her
company and all that but just straight
sex I think it's like a hundred to five
depending on the in person and that's
like but like by an hour also like
hooker hookers yeah I wanna be a escort
or you ask you watch go through the
escort like someone you hire to go on a
trip with you for a weekend know I'm
talking about like dude we saw Harris
yeah okay well the hooker is a hundred
to five hundred with for an hour okay
[Music]